ha aterrizado y en Beijing la secretaria
del tesoro Janeth jellen en el segundo
viaje de un alto cargo estadounidense en
un mes y ahora como ocurrió con el
secretario de estado Anthony blinken ni
china ni Estados Unidos esperan grandes
avances bastará con mantener cierta
normalidad en las comunicaciones y
frenar el deterioro de las relaciones
shelen estará hasta el domingo en la
capital y no está previsto que se reúna
con el presidente pero sí lo hará con el
nuevo equipo económico chino y con
representantes del empresariado de su
país que presionan para que la casa
blanca lime asperezas con Beijing a
favor Beijing juega su perfil es
pragmática globalista y ni siquiera en
los días más áridos defendió el
desacoplamiento que pedían las voces más
hostiles esa desvinculación económica ha
aclarado Sería desastroso para ambos
países y para el mundo entero en contra
juega el contexto los intereses comunes
económicos habían servido en el pasado
para apaciguar las diferencias
geopolíticas pero esos tiempos han
terminado China la menta que Estados
Unidos mantenga aún los aranceles
millonarios a sus exportaciones que
datan de la guerra comercial emprendida
por Donald Trump también lamenta la más
reciente prohibición de vender
semiconductores y otros componentes
tecnológicos a compañías chinas de ginas
respondido en las últimas horas
limitando las exportaciones Estados
Unidos de galio y germanio dos metales
usados en la industria de los chips
equipos de comunicación y defensa ese
ambiente enrarecido se ha encontrado
hielo que en el reparto de roles de la
Casa Blanca ejerce el de